what do the words bread baker mean to
you
icon legend leader of men being the
assistant editor I have the first look
at the raw footage Prez always mentioned
like he's mentioned so much he really is
like another hot sauce Brett Baker is
credibility for hot ones Brett Baker is
our own little New York Times review it
kind of feels like celebrity it would
have been fairly early on when this guy
started tweeting these things out after
an F so it goes out there's gonna be a
million people saying that they didn't
sauce the wing that the guest is stupid
get bill burr the silver lining is going
to be a really insightful reviewer and
buy bread baker like how one superfan
and then finally how do you think
they'll do with this challenge I think
you can do pretty well but I hope I'm
wrong based on when you're doing your
intros when do you talk to the others
all right I know I'm good hey everybody
what's going on for first we feast
I'm Brett Baker and today I'm the host
of hot ones the show with hot questions
and even hotter wings right now I'm
joined by the man the myth the legend
the reason why I watch every week you
know and the iron stomach did inquisitor
to the stars I know him as the man that
loves me more than friends
hey Jon welcome to your show I'm happy
that we could finally make this happen
Brett you guys hit a million subscribers
on YouTube which is one of the reasons
why we're doing that so I'm just lucky
enough to be the rep of the fans so I
hope I represent them well but I am
armed with questions though so I know
and you have the notes out and I don't
think anyone else could do this
interview Brett so I'm actually more
nervous for this than I have any other
out when shoot ever
[Music]
first one sriracha
I hear it's no big deal this is strange
being on this side yeah I've never seen
the labels before as with any good myth
there's an origin story what is your
action of others like when you're like
trying to explain this to people before
it really became a thing so it's funny
because like one time we dug up the
original pitch email and there's only
one complex employee that even responded
to it and it was that way the entire
time like we've always kind of felt that
were this little engine that could but
nobody ever took us that seriously and
then same with the pitch process like
even when we're trying to get
celebrities in here that was always a
weird and interesting thing and there's
times like especially early on where
we'd show up with this circus freak show
and have to kind of explain it in
real-time because it sounds so stupid on
paper and it sounds so stupid when you
explain it to people but that said I
feel like we embrace that like we liked
being the thing that was misunderstood
did you immediately get the psychology
of what the sauce does it breaks down
barriers you've interviewed folks I've
interviewed a lot of people and you know
that there's always women here there's a
show they put out an image they want to
project you know we knew it would strip
people down when you knew there'd be
sweating we knew there'd be spitting in
buckets we knew that it would be an
internet spectacle but we didn't know
that it would yield these incredible
interview moments and that's kind of
what's elevated the show and made it a
real legitimate viable media property in
my opinion is that it doesn't matter who
we drop in here we're either going to
get crazy reactions we're either going
to get a breakthrough interview or we're
going to get some combination of the two
it's a little more origin story except
this time it's on you hmm you graduate
from the University of Illinois less
than 10 years ago true if the day you
got the cap and gown walked the stage
you said 10 years from now where am I
going to be was just where you would say
no and who would you know I was
broadcast journalism major so there was
always this dream or idea that I could
be on TV
the thought originally from my professor
John Paul he said that I was so glib
that I should be a weatherman
so I was like all right cool well I have
to start taking these other science
courses or whatever because I'm never
going to be a meteorologist I need to
have this kind of background and I could
be kind of just like local legend
weatherman in central Illinois and that
would just kind of be my legacy I never
in a million years would have thought
that I'd be in New York City
interviewing celebrities over chicken
wings and odd sauce I thought I'd be a
weatherman number three this one this is
a show about the fans for the fans so we
asked Twitter to fire off some questions
and we've selected a few offers I guess
we have to yeah right right yeah L
Yucatec oh so first up this comes from
electro Specter where did you learn your
interview skills and what is your prep
process the audience has a high bar the
audience has a half that has high
expectations and in this space it's a
very competitive congested space so I
know that I have to stand out I know
that I have to do things differently
reading everything about the person and
to watching their projects and to
reading their books and to deep-diving
their Twitter and deep-diving their
Instagram and trying to figure out
what's there about because I'm already
coming to them with hot sauce and
chicken you know what I mean so I have
to get them to understand very quickly
that this isn't as goofy as it looks on
paper miss J underscore ruby-red asks
are there pictures of you with a full
head of hair there are I just took this
off like three four years ago there's a
whole arc I had like a short sort of 98°
gel situations throughout high school
sometimes I shave it off in the summer
for baseball season sometimes
let it grow out it's never gotten too
crazy because it curls and does like
some weird stuff back here so I never
let it get to that point because it
would drive me nuts and I start to
feather out the back Brett as not
speaking for you but nobody going
through the same thing you're just kind
of like whatever this is I'm just going
to bald gracefully and just take it off
Jasper Mitchell top ten hand gestures of
all time you have a go Joe to me I never
really thought about the hand gestures
is such a thing I've always talked with
my hand I've always been like kind of
known for that but then when you're on
the internet every day everybody just
kind of takes whatever you are and makes
you that thing so I'm like hand gesture
guide but I've never thought of myself
as hand gesture guy I don't think about
these things while they're happening
when I do these big sweeps or whatever
it's just how I'm talking the hands
they're very much idle hands they work
themselves you know what I mean like I
don't think about it it's the letter man
coming out in ah let's see so that was
all right anyway next question so whip
um so that we've got more one two three
four five we have six left so yeah now
we're four so I'm asked question number
four this question of Bret sorry man
mm-hmm it's not as the entire visit is
chili Klaus the actual most interesting
man in the world
because I think he is is when we were
doing the carriage ride video we're just
going through and on the Reaper or
whatever we're like we're gonna eat this
Reaper we're going to ride around for 10
minutes it's obviously going to be a
complete meltdown and very good internet
and so I'm just kind of like in this
pepper moment I'm swimming in it I'm
stuck I'm lost and it's hard to just
kind of keep the show moving but you got
to say some things you know you got to
keep it moving so I'm looking around and
I just said that hey chili Klaus I
wouldn't think that's where they shot
you got mail or whatever I said and then
I chili Klaus just comes in hot with the
dad joke and he's like I think I've got
man
hot mail I think that's where they shot
you got mail wow I think I also got me
odd me and I remember when that hit my
ear I was like chili Klaus is such a pro
because English is not his first
language yet he just comes sliding in
with a dad joke on the spot on a
Carolina Reaper in Central Park and so
that's why I think the chili Klaus is
one of the most talented entertainers in
the world somebody who doesn't get
enough credit but somebody who belongs
on that any red carpet somebody who
belongs at the Oscars chili class way
underrated when we see Asian chili Klaus
eat a Carolina Reaper three here's what
I'll say because that's the first one
you swear you'd never do it again and
then yelled it again if chili Klaus
makes a persuasive case the door is open
you do the deep dive on the Instagram I
decided to go in a little different
direction because there are some moments
in the show that I see your face and I
want to know what's happening in your
brain because you don't have time to
explain it so these are some of my
favorite moments that I've broken down
the screen grabbed and I just wanted to
know what you were thinking okay you
know what show that's from this is Bobby
Lee pooping his pants so so yeah as
that's happening he didn't stop talking
you didn't have a chance so what is
happening in your mind brain right then
that sound in real-time was bizarre you
know what I mean it was like like you I
don't know if something can sound lumpy
but that's what it was it had this like
perfect bass to it it was like somebody
dropped a dumbbell onto like a pile of
laundry all right okay this is just your
guy okay you're about to say it I can
tell okay it's Eric Andre
I know it's Eric Andre because all the
sauces are all over the place so we're
like all we can really do is Eric Andre
proof the set I know what I mean so we
didn't really know what he was going to
break or how he was going to break it or
whatever so to just have him grab the
plate and just go get some baby like
that's what he says something like that
smashes it over his head I don't think
that there's anything you can do but
react like that because I don't think we
put everything that he broke into the
episode I think he broke other things
that didn't make the episode but we left
the studio it was just like it looks
like a tornado and just ripped through
because you just see like all of the
stunts glass and the plates and like all
of this stuff all over the floor it just
looked like a bomb went off was crazy
all right next up for Christchurch
shirtless one of my favorite probably
he's not number one of Power Rankings
but he's probably like my personal
favorite yes but this is when he thought
he was going to spill his lunch that's
just the face that you make when you
feel like something's going to happen
but you don't know how and you don't
know when in this table ain't that big
so I'm kind of also to like positioning
myself to just bail on this whole
situation if it happened eject eject
eject a set oh this is pocalypse mouth
mm-hmm when in this probably the reason
why I'm here
Thank You Russell Brand I love you ah
what was going through your mind when I
haven't bridge because he's a man in
Lincoln Nebraska red he's lovely bread
baker dududududud he's a little list
maker Duden Duden good he's a power rank
baker
his name's Brett Baker bread baker value
me about a third of the way through that
song I realized that whoa this is going
to be a full masterwork you know what I
mean so you just sit back and kind of
enjoy it and then as a host you do kind
of want to anticipate where the energy
is going to drop like we're gonna you
know how is it going to finish how's it
going to end so I was just kind of like
fascinated by and I'm like oh my god is
he gonna work through all these and I
kept waiting for him to stumble and he
never stumbled every day either like
that is pure genius so it was like a dog
that broke loose it was a weird day for
me too
right Baker's Susan is with list maker
see he's a power rank faker his name's
Greg Baker yeah how was it when I mean
we saw your reaction in real time but
yeah I mean it was surreal to watch it
and then like and I had to go in and
work that day but I never had that kind
of moment and where my phone just didn't
shut up you know you are a speech coach
and you work with high school kids and
shout out Malcolm Clippers state write
up a do people think you like bread
thank ya yeah a lot at least two to
three times a week and it never fails to
make me laugh it never fails to make me
smile bread that was for you I've
transcended to a world of rhyme
everything I say now will be poetic
until I eventually just shut down my
consciousness what makes you more angry
about other entities ripping off the hot
ones mom the fact that they do it before
this they don't own up to it
even though we had celebrities come
through I never felt like we were a big
show you know what I mean I felt very
much like we were a junkyard dog
scrapping it out on the YouTube streets
scratching and Klein for every view that
we got so then didn't he
a fox sports Australia blatantly ripping
us off was to me infuriating then on top
of that to see these rugby guys who are
basically like the football Sunday guys
on that Fox or CBS those guys but the
Australian rugby version are like we're
a bunch of crazy guys here and now we
have this new show and it's wild because
you know we're always pushing boundaries
here at Fox Sports Australia the next
day
BBC drops the same thing so I'm like
these are some of the biggest media
companies in the world ripping us off I
feel like we do have something special
here the people who work on the show
work so hard on it and it drove me nuts
what about like a well-intentioned
homage
those are the best you know what I mean
like when I see fans that are doing the
show and they're playing with it and
they're having fun and it's just like
whatever that's the best that's the
thing
kids goofing off having fun love it big
media companies slapping their name on
this idea without giving any credit paid
it
[Music]
how you doing breath burger your own
good I think and we talked about this
before you started rolling um
the thing that helps you maybe you
probably didn't realize this is your
focus so much on the interview is now I
am did you don't have to think about it
when you are figuring out exactly what
hot one was was there anyone that you
look to his inspiration ricky gervais is
called it uh this is like Charlie Rose
meets jackass when he said that I was
like that's the best tagline it's better
than hot questions even hotter wings you
know that's kind of what we've sort of
always thought of ourselves as the
people that inspired us Alexa Chung who
used to do these offbeat interviews on
this show called pop world she's kind of
the hot ones Queen so to speak you know
and and what she did is very much in the
DNA of what we're doing now and then
outside of that I was influenced in a
big way by Howard Stern eggs just
listened to the Howard Stern Show and
Howard Stern interviews and even if he
was talking to somebody who I didn't
care about I always admired his ability
to make whoever he's talking to like a
fascinating conversation to sort of
edge-of-your-seat thing so it's just
trying to like bring it down a level
bring the person down a level and make
it a more human accessible experience so
that's really kind of the hot one DNA if
I'm mixing it up Chris Schoenberger
would probably have his own answer to
that question but that's my
all right this one we're going to test
you again mm-hmm
this is a hot ones trivia all right
longest episode not including Tony Hawk
because that was live Neil deGrasse
Tyson very good 26 minutes to four
seconds I took two bites [ __ ] did I
just say that shortest episode with Tony
Yayo count Tony Yale count
I need eyes it was the pilot until today
so encounter consistency you met the
origin of the dab that's very early
Machine Gun Kelly boom nailed it yeah
well I don't want for my dad woman I
think that's mine I think what I got is
fine right there i primed Evan up you're
not going to dab up oldest and youngest
guests oldest oldest guest Tommy Chong
mm-hmm 77 now we're talking youngest
guest Martin garrix very good 20 nailing
it when did a hot one sauce make it to
baby who was the S with the beginning of
the season or would it be in the middle
of the season would be very hot ones to
just put it in the middle with a
currency and it was not Joey Fatone
Joey Fatone Joey Joey was a tough one
yep April 7th 2016 was at least that was
the day was uploaded YouTube hey next
trivia question only you know the answer
to this is from the staff how many
hoodies do you want oh good I just have
this image of a closet full of 97
hoodies also I think less different than
the next I think we've shot about 80
episodes
and I probably wear hoodies in like 3/4
of them yes so that would lead me to
believe and then you know there's
obviously hoodies in my closet that I've
never worn on the show so that would
take my total number of hoodies for were
to estimate at about 55 weeks I must
have like 55 hoodies all right so I
guess well that's that so now we are on
to the moment of truth the last one so I
don't know if you know it but it's
tradition around I love that you're
taking the wheel did we dab these I will
say I'm a fan of the schmear instead the
dab their channel so green that yeah I
like it is schmear uh no idea if I'm
here and I'm doing it for the fans yes I
got to do it I got to do it you know the
proper way so thank you crazy
that is a little crazy yeah yeah well
you know we came this far what the heck
are you reading all right
I'm only imagining the kind of music
Murphy's going to put under this Bret
you're handling this very well
way better than my celebrities do and
well you know if you ever need a pinch
like you get wow you did put a lot less
on there well I guess you're the guest
now you can do that there's no rules
yeah I have nothing to prove Mimi I'll
do the schmear and the day yeah yeah all
right your studio long good thing at
this point you're saying I've already
drank everything that's been cleared out
of my nose so I don't have anything left
which is good but I agree I'm oftentimes
you talk about the de bomb is the worst
I agree I think that one's got more
sting to it mm-hmm
then these two that breath I wanted to
ask you like so many questions like that
maybe I still will because okay
yeah because now that you're sat here
not your thought my show it's your show
breath yeah let's let's let's attack
some conspiracy theories here excellent
so hold Wingate
you know everybody always like every hot
ones fans they get so worked up about
the wings all the time the wings better
than you thought they'd be worse than
you thought they'd be colder than you
thought they'd be warmer than you
thought they'd be I think they're about
what I expected so we've been talking
for a long time they don't know how
long's your SEP show to run but if
you're naked kind of room temperature at
some point it's not like you're sitting
down at your wing joint right and you're
firing them down and by the way they're
not served cold there is a heater back
there so they actually come out hot I
can verify that now as a man of the
people you know because the DJ Khaled
episode is probably the most divisive
you know what I mean there's there's one
comment that's like this is the best hot
ones episode ever there's the next
comment this is the worst things is the
worst video on the internet ever where
do you fall on that scale somewhere on
the spectrum where are you on dj khaled
it's tough because Chris knows my
barometer really for the ranking so
you've always asked my back
is can the history of the show be told
without that person I love that and the
history of how it's can't be told
without Kali because he is such a big
star and he did say such a punk way out
um like just doing man okay nah I'm we
[ __ ] up with a whole day I also tell
anybody that this we did it we did it we
did it I did it
ah yeah so there you go how do you feel
I feel great uh you know I have to be
real with you this is like is I've never
been more nervous for a shoe than I was
for this one just because I knew that
you would bring the heat and I do want
to say like I don't know if I'm taking
plug time right now but I just want to
say that uh I want to say thank you for
coming out and then the other thing is
you know maybe the biggest of all is I
want to just thank the hot ones and to
have stuck with us through a lot from
season 1 to season 2 all the way through
season 3 and hopefully beyond that even
do I get a plug even though I didn't get
if you have what yeah hi this camera
back there um hey look yeah your I'm a
speech coach support the fine arts in
your community high schools junior
High's drama speech whatever it is band
music we all put a lot of energy and
time into football basketball baseball
track and those are all awesome things
that do great things for our kids but so
do the fine arts so if your parents if
you're somebody is in value community
support the fine arts
well that grub yeah
are you well I thought maybe I was by
now immediately now I'm not going to be
after that first hairy wing I bet you're
going to be any good hey what's going on
hot ones fans if you like the video
maybe meet us halfway throw us a
subscribe if you didn't like the video
don't subscribe I don't want you I don't
want you in the tent but if you liked
the video subscribe thank you very much
I appreciate you I love you more than a
friend